those in the industry say they really
hope to be eligible soon
orco mana joining us live from the las
vegas strip on this friday night with
their concerns
orca well brian hospitality workers here
on the las vegas strip
often have to closely interact with
visitors they say the kovit 19 vaccine
would give them some peace of mind
but it's still unclear when they can get
it
it's upsetting and there's a lot of us
in this city that do this
julie greco is a server at slice of
vegas inside the shops at mandalay place
she and other workers on the las vegas
strip
are still waiting to get the kovid 19
vaccine something they desperately want
just have that safety blanket basically
i would really appreciate that
that's because many customers travel
from out of town and the interactions
are face to face
in order to be able to hear somebody
that i'm serving i being six feet away
is hard so
i feel like we're a little bit closer
than some other professions i'm a little
scared to come to work sometimes
managers say with more business due to
loosening restrictions protection from
the virus is crucial right now it would
just be great if we all could just be
100 percent
safe get the vaccine and
be able to just do our job it's very
vague of when we're getting it
according to the state's vaccination
playbook food service and hospitality
workers are in the next eligible group
but the southern nevada health district
tells me there's no set timeline for
that yet
some employers like the juice standard
at the cosmopolitan are encouraging
their workers to get on weightless
just to see if that was an option if
they do have
end of day doses that are going to go to
waste because no dose should go to waste
greco says when she is eligible be one
of the first people calling
now hospitality workers add that with
capacity limits set to increase to 50
percent on march 15th
they're hoping they can start getting
vaccinated before that
reporting live on the las vegas strip
tonight orca mana 8 news now